el gigante de la tecnología google está
en la mira de la justicia estadounidense
por supuesta infracción de la ley de
competencia en otras palabras por abusar
de su posición para mantener un
monopolio ilegal en el mecanismo de
búsqueda por internet
el departamento de justicia ha
determinado que una respuesta
antimonopolio es necesaria para
beneficiar a los consumidores si el
gobierno no lo hace cumplir y creo que
debemos permitir la competencia
podríamos perder la próxima ola de
innovación si eso sucede los
estadounidenses tal vez nunca lleguen a
ver el próximo google
casi de inmediato la poderosa compañía
del silicon valley que abarca el 80 por
ciento de las búsquedas en computadores
y el 90% en celulares respondió en
twitter la demanda de hoy del
departamento de justicia es
profundamente defectuosa
la gente usa google porque decide
hacerlo no porque se vea obligada a
hacerlo o porque no pueda encontrar
alternativas el departamento de justicia
acusa a google de pagar cada año a los
fabricantes de teléfonos a los
operadores y a los navegadores web miles
de millones de dólares de sus ingresos
de publicidad para que sea el motor de
búsqueda predeterminado
tienen ventaja competitiva en la
búsqueda todo el mundo lo sabe
bing no es tan bueno y eso es lo que
impulsa nuestro negocio entonces por qué
castigas a alguien que se ha
diferenciado con éxito en un mercado
competitivo ese va a ser el argumento y
tiene algo de credibilidad
prince en 2019 la unión europea condenó
al gigante a pagar una multa de casi
1.800 millones de dólares por el mismo
motivo una cifra que contrasta con los
millones de dólares que acumuló la
compañía en el mismo año y más que lo
ganado por la nación de hungría